see what gillnet [ __ ] me up what's
going on everybody for first we feast on
Sean Evans and you're watching hot one
it's a show with hot questions and even
hotter wing and today I'm joined by
Russell Brand he's known the world over
for his book his films his stand-up
comedy and speaking up will be going on
a tour beginning in April called Russell
Brand rebirth Russell welcome to the
show
thank you what was that even just the
concept of hot food began to hurt my
mouth oddly I think I've got older I was
going to ask you how are you with
absolute look good like I say I was
having a curry I've have a cool mod has
like a pasty sort of fluid so you
wouldn't go with the vindaloo no I'd
have liked something sorbet I like baby
food let me just come off the breast
well it's important to note we're going
vegan wings today for Russell Brand we
got them from the temple of satan all
hail satan i'm EULA's not underworld
Kingdom but the hot sauces are all still
very much the same for better or worse
Rumble you're ready to get it going
yes please
[Music]
all right so the first one is sriracha
sriracha is no big deal right even if
our baby food guy like you
this is I'll have to register whether or
not I'm going to have a good time
because this is that it should be
nothing but in the bar okay oh no I'm
sorry
I want to start by talking about the
tour rebirth because the name would
imply you know a new beginning and
overhaul yeah
in what ways do you think for lack of a
better term you've been born again new
you have a baby at transitions your
worldview immediately these new
important person just moved into the
house also of course has profound
limitless love that awakens within you
is the end of philandering at the end of
madness at the end of so many things at
the beginning of so many things is the
beginning of an other centered life
exposed what is but like when I think of
dad that's someone else our Father who
are in heaven here somewhat that's God
or someone else anymore and out who I am
him who don't make of a cure that
fermius manageable this ism within the
realm of the place in that go vanilla
sexual activity at this point no one's
got anything PVC or leather out and I'm
suggesting scrapping you out I know that
you have a deep fondness for your
favorite football team and that's what
Ham United
so I'm sure that the barefaced green and
capitalism of professional sports
hi I'm is all that predict now that we
get into the pair adult it's a lot of it
always is with Russell I love West Ham
United's but whether the sport continues
to become commercialized do I feel
challenged but that allegiance has been
reappropriation system if they'll have a
pure place in your heart when I was a
West Ham fan in 1980 the problem was the
West Ham United was considered to be
racist
violent although going now these are the
sport has become commodified the problem
becomes well how does this relate to
indigenous roots is a sport of
working-class people and representatives
of the people of Britain besides
organism what's the best way to channel
your hatred for another club like Saint
Chelsea FC why organism should be taken
off of the possible expression Sean is
through song like speaker
up your arse up your ass kick your
balloon flag after our from Stamford
Bridge dr. Park stick your blues flag up
your ass that would be the way of
expressing that not through violence and
hatred but from jaunty sweary aiming
centric so man have you done this with a
woman is what happened how was she
we've had four women on the show it's
overwhelmingly male our viewers are
overwhelmingly male but the women that
we've had and perform much better than
the guys on average because somewhere in
their reservoir they have got I will let
baby come out of my shell yeah like a
much higher pain tolerance so I'm going
to talk about Donald Trump for a second
because in addition to being a staple in
your truth series you actually had
direct contact with them as he's want to
do he called you a major loser on
Twitter one time yeah he did call me
back but I will add emojis it was nice
to me he had me round his tower I think
that actually you know what a live
America he was very sweet generally
speaking then he took me to his office
and it goes to me and if anyone seen any
one thing you want from the office and
that's what was it Willy Wonka [ __ ]
you had like like we had good shame Emma
I'd like Muhammad Ali the heavyweight
bill I was really tempted got [ __ ] at
that every way Bill Nye if you don't
mind at all so put that on and wear it
and go round in Muhammad Ali's bill I
didn't that just took a pin so as I
didn't seem needy and you know you have
a very interesting way of unpackaging it
and reacting to the election and I can't
really tell so maybe you can clue me in
here are you optimistic about the future
or do you feel like we've sort of put
the foot on the gas pedal and now we're
accelerating towards the end of days I
feel the Fulmer actually shown that
there's a reason to be optimism because
a lot of undeclared things at once
become declare for me it seems like the
end of a certain type of politics were a
class of people said they would take
care of another class of people and most
people thought well this isn't working
either things get better or they don't
and if they don't where is there now for
people that believe in nationalism where
is there now for people that find that
kind of rhetoric appealing is indeed
that is what determines their election
bill
are we entering the realm of the
challenge now because this is got all
for me and that's quite a potent symbol
revolves in totemism a worthless their
dangerous thing a lone wolf or your wolf
comparison is actually a rather poetic
segue into my next question because I'm
a little disappointed that you didn't
bring bear today on that little bastard
I shoot a bull in O six damn then you go
but would you have minded I would have
loved to be brought bear she's a
brilliant dog but he is no respecter of
convention or order he's a real handful
so I would have loved to boot him
because he is fun but he does not
respect boundaries he's just pure libido
life force well one of my favorite
things that you share it when you
serenade bear see movie and because I
like to think that the dog understands
me in a true and essential way you know
you look at animals eyes when you're
given or lonely in that anything being
animal it loves me no matter what it
doesn't care if I failed or if I've left
myself in the world down this dog who
loved me so I start to think I'm going
to sing songs we express this idea to
dog he liked the gray crooners very much
she's a fan of Sinatra Dean Martin
he's uniformly and judgmental of all
races and all types of music and I think
I will be doing some DMX track to him
yeah coming soon of that kind of stuff I
think would be quite effective where do
people start freaking out zombie
apocalypse so until I get there
this is just a nice chat with a charming
man who looks a bit like Justin
Timberlake as wow I love that I will
take that to the bank thank you so much
this one quite meaty nugget if I may say
Taemin lime we're throwing up I'm not
saying about an unfair advantage except
for your years of experience in the John
room so I want to talk about one of my
favorite videos when you're on the
private jet with Vinnie and he described
you I think is his best friend rusty
rocket fortunately that relationship is
injured Gideon I have no I'm not seeing
Diddy for a wee while but I must say I
continue to be most grateful for that
sort of a Helsing summer we're a regular
part of my life with Sean
boom but we had sort of a caste dinner
for the film that we were doing I was a
respectable hour late he was nowhere to
be seen he come round where people were
like having like sort of coffee and
forgiving Sean Puff Daddy combs burst in
in sort of like us of a cloud of his own
charisma it was magnificent and he
instructed us that we were going to
Vegas on a private jet and told me I had
to organise tickets for Ricky Hatton's
fight versus Manny Pacquiao and I did
have to organise tickets by ringing up
Ricky Hatton the boxer who at that time
was very nervous and preoccupied with
his forthcoming boxing match with Manny
Pacquiao's can we get tickets he didn't
return a message something's happening
to my consciousness is that the so does
fear the shortest route engine it's all
Happy's kicking in mm-hm
gotta miss trunks with the bulking ring
you have to be very near the bulking
ring avoid it's not good enough I was in
I've got tickets for the fourth row
puffy Sears national good we were
getting the third row so in the end of
it puffy out to sort out those tickets
then jay-z was there and I'm owning my
life Wells with Jay Z from P Diddy and
Manny Pacquiao would just locks out
Ricky Hatton really was standing on his
chair shouting from the majority of the
audience all English and therefore when
I fought on unusual for the Queen
I liked it
you've never been shy about your
criticisms of the media via the BBC or
Fox News which you called a fanatical
terrorists propaganda group what I want
to do is pull up some of the biggest
most influential names and mass
communication and then you just give me
the fertility that comes to your mind
that's good I won't give you the first
thing that comes to my mind because
that's always something that nearly
lands me in prison
Mark Zuckerberg now look above what
precedes this sort of like you know
warlike media barons of the 1920s so
it's an unprecedented power
unprecedented responsibility still a
very young man how old is he 34 though
that's only do I still change my voice
slightly to people that are very forward
are you alright mate but like you know
you could add me killed using binary all
right what about Rupert Murdoch I'm
trying to see the divine in everyone
these days it's all like being tolerant
and loving about people that you
identify live in acknowledged
but the more someone looks like a ball
bag the harder it is to see that
divinity and that's why we have to try
to reach within the scrotal and to the
divine within him
what about megyn kelly I must say I'm
quite vulnerable to right-wing women
that are conventionally attractive
because for me there's some sort of
dovetailing of the presumed
philosophical cruelty and the beauty
will make people god you're so gorgeous
beautiful I think you would you look
after me what about our journey he
amazing actually he's another one he's
enough one of these great media
originators he deconstructed radio while
it was happening so I learned over the
years have that them so something mental
voice like manageable mental that's
where I live in the marketplace how it's
turned he plucks out of the window
because like he'll get you saying [ __ ]
making housing blows I mean it's like
he's like a sort of a brilliant producer
you just come home with your nicotine
ran bag so and I didn't mean a [ __ ] that
guy I feel not nervous like it's
affected me I've fallen into the
structure of the river show I have to
say this though you look great you're
doing fine usually by this time if
you're somebody who comes in here
they're like I'm not going to have food
there's little space sweat they're like
hiccuping a little bit you're doing
great thank you so much no I eat it
[Music]
even noon was the experience probe
mm-hmm that's quite a cool
it'll hit your throat a little bit you
know that's a throat yes that's that's
challenging your name shagger of the
year three times in a row by the Sun as
we just discussed you're now a new
father
what's your prouder accomplishment as a
fornicator the gifts of fornication
my glorious child or the accolade nor
shagging dagger of the Europe I must I
must be honest with you Shona
they never verified the quality of any
of that shagging or even the quantity
they never asked any of the shagged
partners whether they were happy with
the Shaggs whether they were legitimate
checks whether they'd actually happened
they simply saw that I was emerging from
a lot of nocturnal dwellings with
numerous other humans and assumes that
it was cause of shagging and I fool that
I was desperate for approval than I
continue to be and allow this
misapprehension to continue so I would
say that it is the burgeoning new life
and the witnessing of the emergence of
consciousness and the possibility for
redemption that every parent has that is
the greater achievement not to undermine
the shagging because it was top not
shagging that are done now we go to the
debar beyond infinity beyond insanity
what we are yawns infinitely possibly
another form of sanity you never know
about a reason let's go there okay me do
I get a souvenir from doing this program
you get our plug at the end right
so a little bit you know whatever thinks
about that I do it's not easy to
interview when you're doing this thing
with hot sauce all the time you know no
because I can at least be spontaneous
but you've got to adhere to a structure
you marry this you've got to provide
morale you're the focal point for
enticing people all I've got to do is
just open abstractor my tongue hung
precise and sleeping on it now so I want
to talk about your YouTube serious
truths for a second because it seems to
be filling this place in the marketplace
where the real mainstream news is kind
of letting its audience down and then
it's kind of crazy too because you have
this global phenomenon with fake news
you have the highest office peddling
Alternatives facts at what point is the
truth just so devalued that it's not
even worth searching for anymore never
because what do we have other than our
own essential experience of the world
but there are challenges with a concept
such as the truth because I suppose
there's what 14 people in this room each
of our family different experience
people hear me in the crew have their
imperatives and objectives well we know
one of these people could have been
heartbroken today so even in a confined
social system such as this room there
are numerous troops numerous realities
and our job as human being is to be
sympathetic empathetic and
bridge-building with other people's
truths not spamming condemning and
maliciously and deliberately confused
so truth is more important than it has
ever been the profligacy and
availability of information means that
we have to be responsible with
information and responsible with truth
now what's happening to me is these
sources have become like they're
affecting with the level of
consciousness on that I feel like it's
the being the matrix where Neos picking
bullets out there I am looking at and
realizing it's just code if they're a
leaderboard in a leaderboard a league
table is a graph that I can be on we
have this super fan who tweets others
power ranking it gets really into them
what's your name
his name's Brett Baker great I'd like to
reach out to you presumably in America
giving you a call Brett Baker likely to
bear that statement in mind when judging
me when I'm at the cleverly respectable
level of 3 5 7 mantle you know like in a
point isn't there where know like these
are already dead you know like you're
just punching a corpse now so I want to
talk about your show ponder line for a
second because why that's so long ago no
no it is I'll tell you why because they
had a very interesting quote about your
relationship with food you said that you
only want to eat food that is perfectly
geometric dollops do you remember that
line perfectly geometric you think
you'll research you brilliant me and
Chris where's Chris Chris raise your
hand
I'm I'm eight oh well yes I did say I
only want to eat perfectly geometric
Daleks does you learn anything about
cooking from hanging out with Jamie
Oliver
no I'm shitty I know a few proper chefs
Jamie Tom carrot she's a good UK chef
Gordon Ramsay within look it's like a
kind of alchemy although I did make my
girlfriend sausage and mash just
yesterday we have onion gravy and I'm
cooked to run a beam and a foot lease
like purple carrot cabbage [ __ ] on the
edge to make it look more good on an elf
on out the other side there was a moment
where I hi I remembered I feel we're
looking by the nature of consciousness
and laugh and all that you where you
right now
now that make food like that
monosyllabic grump
all right Russell we have one more wing
to go
then lappas what are you shaking it like
that it is tradition around here to put
a little extra dab of hot sauce on the
laceration you don't have to if you
don't want to rotate like John I look
like I'm not good enough
I love oddly a lot of our presenters are
quite a gentle skin obviously it's very
competitive person you describe yourself
as a volatile person before I'm a
volatile person without malice I'd like
to compress squeeze and okay that's good
that's good that's good don't hurt
yourself this isn't about like this is
not kind of Kazi who's not orals you had
this is not martyrdom with the mouth
where the only thing that matters is
there we are civilized people of being
there speaking with me ready no sigh all
my past is coming back let's talk about
it bloody thing I didn't enjoy the first
time so I've got me the bit that's got
the enema
that would be the point and also this is
particularly dog-eared nugget summer
wing in your life are you enjoying the
vision actually yes pretty good right in
the early days back there at the other
end of the smorgasbord when it wasn't
about carving my mouth up with raises of
flavor it was glorious remember me Jesus
[Music]
what do think Brett Butler is negative
all this but maker Brett write down well
what do you think he's making up all
this you know I'm [ __ ] to flip out
when he says Russell Brand you're
talking to him directly he's like this
Brett is like a random TV producer in
Lincoln Nebraska who just loves hot ones
and just writes these Power Rankings up
all the time you know losin mine Brit
Baker's good he's a man in Lincoln
Nebraska read he's a lovely breathtaker
the decision he's a LITTLEST makeup
student isn't he the power rank Baker
his name's Brett Baker bread baker value
me read Baker can't you see I'm drinking
milk cutting through all the hot sauces
my tongues on fire [ __ ] call me a liar
but we've been through strike a hot
chili sauce Tabasco elucidate he thinks
we've been through the war we've tried
the hot one we have even had Ghost
Pepper blueberry and consciously
breadmaker we went through the
apocalypse they burnt my husband and I
continued on to bomb Brad Baker it
wasn't enough to blow up a British brand
my dog three point five seven I stared
down the barrel I'm singing you this
chiral prospective let's take it to the
end old bread take a breath cuz we've
taken down the [ __ ] Megadeth
Brett Brett that was for you I've
transcended to a world of rhyme
everything I say now will be poetic
until I eventually just shut down my
consciousness that is amazing there's no
point in asking a question because you
can't go anywhere from there Russell you
made it through you cleared the board
white hot sauce brain on fire saying of
the
this camera this camera that camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life I'm pregnant now I'm having
a baby made out in vegan snacks and
science he will be available in its show
called Russell Brand Reba it's me
standing still talking hey what's on
that [ __ ] me up
hello hello ruff I'll have a gone very
positive it is well Jim repose it is
what about going into this though oh
well I'm not so because like but
explaining to my girlfriend yesterday
what this was and she goes you're not
like good in spicy food even in the just
context of normal but this isn't a
normal context you know maybe you
already this time in context but maybe
you're good in that extreme pass so you
said I'm not that good at fighting even
who was just a general fight in a bar
but was born your wage fighting but if
it was for your life you'd be a better
fighter I think also raising this brand
you know say I'm doing is beneficial as
I'm saying so also at expect can bikinis
explode exposing weakness right that's
kind of this that's that's the challenge
that's the challenge hey what's going on
hot ones fans if you like the video
maybe meet us halfway throw us a
subscribe if you didn't like the video
don't subscribe I don't want you I don't
want you in the tent
but if you liked the video subscribe
thank you very much I appreciate you I
love you more than a friend